now the question in my mind is what's
the most exciting innovation and
development over the next decade that
will improve the state of the world oh
that's pretty sure that is the full
integration of women into political
participation to economic observation
into ensuring that all the rows around
the world will see the same education as
boys and that the health resources of
countries the divided equally between
down and women because our we're
beginning to see now some of the results
of having women more actively in the
public sphere and those results look
pretty darn good and so to me we need to
continue that innovation of getting
women more into the public spaces and I
will hope and think that it will what I
fall hurry history